this is Startalk how about this let's go
to a patreon patron question and this is
from Dillon Hallahan who supports us on
patreon at which you can do as well and
by doing so you will be allowed to have
priority given to your particular
enquiries so just keep that in mind
Dillon would like to know this are there
any ways we can create a virtual
singularity where we can represent the
beginning Dillon is coming to us from
Washington Township in New Jersey so
would we be able is there enough
information about you know I'm of course
the background radiation is always there
and it's always happening but the event
itself the singularity itself could we
do we have enough information to
recreate a visual representation of that
singularity to some degree I would say a
little bit after you know in the
universe starts to expand yeah so we
can't get the birth but we could maybe
get but a slap on the ass the baby slap
on the ass we could get but we couldn't
get the actual you know you might get
that first cry or the first cry but not
the actual you know it's crowning like
that that we we don't know okay why we
don't know we can serve describe what
what and back to a certain point but so
that very beginning is is something that
we extrapolate our physics right the
point of the the greatest pressure and
temperatures that and then we test this
and the largest you know atom smashers
in the world you know like it's CERN and
and so forth to really kind of look at
what those conditions are right mystery
when you try to go all of all them all
the way about that that's right first
tiny fraction of a second right very
hard to get information so we're left
with theory and arists of course like to
argue with one another
and then and then looking at how the
universe expands and and that we can
track that to some degree and and that's
a visualization of that by Tom Abba and
his visualizer Ralph Caylor is in dark
universe if you come see that and so
sweet devolution of essentially
structure over time the universe is
expanding but locally its contracting
because of gravity and so you end up
with this giant sort of web in this
cosmic web which we actually observe you
can even in a small telescope you can go
out I grew up in New Jersey and you
could look up and the constellation
Virgo that's what's called the Virgo
cluster and you see you see galaxies
even even a small telescope so here
you're looking at a local area of
downtown which we are not and in the
same way that we're sort of in the
suburbs of the galaxy is probably a good
thing it's a good place to raise the
kids about we're so uptight here on
earth because we're living in the suburb
of the galaxy well it's a little more
stable than the raucous ride in the
middle of it okay when we grow up we can
go downtown downtown right the center of
the galaxy the really good radiation I'm
not by yourself and not unaccompanied
young man and I mean that